do black lives matter in Israel if you
ask some of the Ethiopian Jews who are
citizens of the state it doesn't feel
that way they've taken to the streets
over the past several weeks to protest
police brutality and racism in Israeli
society and the should be confused with
the recent protests of African migrants
who aren't Jewish and are seeking asylum
but back to the Ethiopian these waves of
protest were ignited in April after a
video and viral of police violently
beating an Israeli soldier of Ethiopian
descent and as Israel based journalist
and filmmaker David Sheen told me that
struck a chord with many pretty much
every single Ethiopian Jewish man in
this country can speak to that
experience either he's experienced it
personally or his brother or his uncle
or his friends that have been the
victims of police brutality so what
should you know about the Ethiopian
Jewish community in Israel today at
least 135,000 Ethiopian Jews to live in
the country which is approximately 2% of
the population many of them arrived
after Israel airlifted them out during
the years of the famine in the 1980s and
90s before that thousands of Ethiopians
tried to reach Israel by land many dying
on the journey but today despite the
fact that these black Jews of Israel are
citizens of the state which entitles
them to equal protection under Israeli
law and despite the fact that they serve
in the Israeli army and speak fluent
Hebrew they have long been the victims
of systemic discrimination just how bad
is it obviously being the darkest huge
Jews in the country they face this color
based discrimination that's not unlike
in the United States in other parts of
the world the Ethiopian community has
not been allowed to access to housing
all over the country they were sent to
certain community and other communities
refused them they were sent to certain
schools and other schools refused them
they've also suffered endemic poverty at
least 65 percent of Ethiopian children
lives below the poverty line just five
percent of the community have college
degrees compared with 28 percent of the
broader Jewish population and on top
that 1/5 of the inmates and juvenile
facilities are Ethiopian Israelis as
organizer maurya's Alka told me the
younger generation of Ethiopian Israelis
are fighting to change all of that we
were born here or raised here we get the
education here so we know our rights we
know what we want until once the result
but true result and a long term results
we won't stop so given the community's
demands for social justice today what is
the government doing well Prime Minister
Netanyahu met with the Ethiopian Israeli
soldier who was beaten by police and
told him Netanyahu repeated that
sentiment at an annual memorial for the
4,000 Ethiopian Jews who died on their
way to Israel years ago saying there is
no place for racism and discrimination
in our society he's also set up a
ministerial committee to eradicate
racism but is that enough
many black Jews believe that change will
only come with a change of consciousness
among Israelis as a whole and given how
small the Ethiopian community is and the
fact that it doesn't have a lot of
political power how optimistic should
folks be that the government will once
and for all address these long-standing
concerns which their female be involved
with Unity Party